everybody's talking about cbdc Central
Bank digital currency some are saying
it's a great idea you know my question
is
in that similar vein what would make a
well-designed uh cdpc system that helps
overcome some of these existing issues
that we have seen with banks and with
just the delivery of stimulus checks
some are saying it's a horrible idea are
you interested in giving these economic
Central planners more power over our
economy more power over your daily life
and your economic activity and I answer
that question he double double hockey
sticks no who's right all right so if
you get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
let's get right into it what is cbdc the
easiest way to explain it is think about
Bitcoin right it's a decentralized
currency that's used but it's
decentralized no one's regulating it no
one knows who owns it now imagine if a
Bitcoin currency is created but it's
controlled and regulated by the
government that's CBD see so how much
momentum are they creating with the sole
concept of cbdc who's Ford who's against
it according to atlanticcouncil.org in
May 2020 only 35 countries were
considering a cbdc today 114 countries
are exploring cbd's equal to 95 of the
global GDP currently 60 countries are in
the advanced phases of exploring their
own cbdc while in the last two years 11
countries have already launched their
own currency into full operations we're
talking Nigeria Bahamas Angela Dominica
Granada St Lucia Montserrat St Vincent
Saints kids Nevis and most recently
Jamaican obviously these are all small
countries they don't have high gdps but
G7 economies have now entered a
development stage of cbdc and China's
pilot is said to be rolled out to most
of the country sometime this year and on
top of that 18 of the G20 countries are
now in the advanced stages of cbdc
development and nearly every G20 country
has invested a significant amount of
time and resources into the projects
over the past six months so obviously
we're far along this isn't something
that they're just kind of playing around
with but what do you think you think
it's a good idea or a bad idea here's
what they're saying the pros and the
cons are Pros increase payment
efficiency complement current forms of
money and financial services deter
criminal activity improve International
payment options potentially reduce a net
transaction costs benefiting lower
income households so now here are the
cons overhauling The Current financial
system could create instability the
effectiveness of monetary policy May
deteriorate operational difficulty cyber
security risk and last but not least
privacy as there is a loss of ability to
transact anonymously so let's talk about
that one anonymously do you like to be
anonymous for what you're purchasing
what if I ask you right now you go to
your job and I'm the boss I'm trying to
hire you for a job and I say hi before
we consider you as an employee could you
please submit all your credit card and
your expenditure on what you've spent
the last 90 days or you know six months
we'd like to see what your buying habits
are what would you say to me
actually what would you say to me are
you not upset right now or offended
right now you'd say who the hell are you
to ask me a question like that you know
when was the last time somebody asked
you whether you tracked everything you
bought you were probably 17 years old
and you were using mommy or Daddy's
credit card they tracked every one of
your purchases why because you were a
kid so let me get this straight U.S
government I'm 44 years old a grown man
of four kids and you get to see
everything I buy invest in what kind of
data does that give you do you now
automatically you can go based on seeing
what purchases people make and say I
know where this guy leans I know what
this guy's doing I know what that guy's
doing let's help this guy with more
financing let's hurt this guy let's
write that so you know what I'm saying
so are you okay with people tracking
everything you're buying you're
purchasing decision making process and
what if all of a sudden you get too loud
then what if right now like the
silencing of somebody is if you are
against vaccine but it may be something
else that you're from now five years
from now 10 years from now what if you
have an opinion what if there's a
culture War again in 10 years 20 years
30 years you're like no I'm not against
these robots doing this what if one
thing like a robot can be a better
president than the average person let's
vote for Robert are you out of your mind
are you serious but if all of a sudden
you fight against it hey bring that
access down here you can't say too much
you know his digital currency or digital
what if now somebody may say Pat that's
not going to be happening okay no
problem I think an author back in the
days wrote a business book called only
the paranoid survived Andy Grove let's
stay a little bit paranoid okay I want
you to think about this who's for it
well the top five banks are for it they
think cbdc is a great idea why would
Chase be of a well City why would these
guys want cbdc well because there's not
a Founder in those Banks those banks are
pretty much working for the US
government no they're not yes they are
the government dictates the rates the
government gives the money the
government bails them out they have to
work with the government on a daily
basis pretty much so they're pretty much
owned by the government not necessarily
it's still on the stock market but they
communicate more with the government
than they do with you they don't want no
Bitcoin to blow up they want cbdc with
Bitcoin they can't control you it's
decentralized they like AI Control are
you okay with the way they're thinking
if you are you should be for cbdc
Elizabeth Warren is for cbdc AOC is for
cbdc U.S government is for cbdc who's
not for cbdc free thinkers entrepreneurs
Libertarians guys who are innovators
disruptors who want to live their lives
and kind of be left alone they want to
make the decisions that they're making
and as long as they don't break the laws
they're kind of going out there about
themselves these guys don't want to be
controlled so this whole cbdc thing
comes down to two things
if you like to be controlled you're for
cbdc if you want to think for yourself
and not be controlled you're not for
cbdc if you like somebody else to make
decisions for you you are for cbdc if
you want to think for yourself and if
you make mistake great no problem you
pay the price for it no problem you're
not for cbdc this is what it's really
coming out to and by the way many many
years ago when everybody was talking
about Bitcoin I said my biggest fear
about Bitcoin is Bitcoin
scares the most powerful institution in
the world which is the US government
governments don't like when they cannot
control a currency they can't control
Bitcoin they're going to do whatever
they can to trash it bash it they'll
talk about all the criminal activity
that happens in Bitcoin to get people to
eventually say yes this is not a good
idea it's better if the government
controls it and then you'll go over here
and then all of a sudden 10 years later
you're like
this was a bad idea but it's too late by
now everybody's using their money
through they saw cbdc that they're
selling to and by the way you know how
they say things like well look we're
becoming a cashless Society how many
places are you going to nowadays that
they don't even accept cash yeah but
we've been using cards for a long time
and it's okay well the fees are high
what if you can save three percent I'm
okay paying three percent fees in the
money that I'm transferring and it takes
in a day or two and no one knowing about
my decision except me and that credit
card company then you the government
knowing exactly what everybody else is
doing again Freedom you're not for cbdc
control you are for cbdc but I want to
hear your thoughts if you got value from
today's episode give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and comment
below and by the way a part of why
they're able to capitalize office to
sell the American people on cbdc being a
good thing it's because of what happened
with Silicon Valley in the banking
crisis I did a private webinar on that a
week ago if you've never seen it it's
data Intel we've never shared before our
research and pulled up all this data I
highly recommend you're seeing it click
here to watch the banking crisis webinar
thank you everybody bye-bye
foreign